if there is some risk related to co2
emissions and you know greenhouse effect
and all that stuff why not just at this
moment just start a massive transition
to green well so we can talk about green
but but you might make the air be a
stronger argument if it were
alternatives and then reconducted okay
so that's why the greens are
anti-nuclear answer harder hydro which
are the only decent non co2 right okay
so let's do that then so they'd hear
what you said that okay I buy all of
that right that being said if it's still
putting out some bad stuff into the
atmosphere and we're not sure what
exactly what that's going to do and even
if we cut our emissions in the United
States that India and China are still
going through what we went through 50
years ago and they're going to keep one
of us about why not just make that
transition anyway so there's a couple
issues here but one is thinking in the
full context means being really clear
about magnitudes the one is what is the
magnitude of superiority of what the
fossil fuel industry is doing versus the
others and then what is the magnitude of
the downsides so let's say
hypothetically
so Al Gore gave the speech in 2008 Al
Gore my favorite person here your buddy
will get my letter but he said we should
outlaw by the year 2018 all what he
calls non renewable sources of power so
basically he wanted solar wind and some
geothermal and he claimed we could do
this in he claimed I know of renewable
sources that can generate energy for the
equivalent of less than a dollar gallon
of gasoline now I've asked what this is
he still has not named this source but
he was willing to outlaw all of American
energy right in order to do it so and at
the same time he would claim that were
decades away from 20-foot sea level
rises which would be a very very
negative thing you know very very hard
to justice that's kind of one scenario
of magnitudes where fossil fuel industry
actually has no magnitude of superiority
in terms of generating energy and it has
an incredible damage right an incredible
downside but what if it was true that
say we had a minor amount of warming and
that the fossil fuel industry was just
way wet was generations ahead of
everyone else in terms of a transition I
think the implication would be in
I think this is implication no matter
what is that you would want a free
market transition so you'd want to look
at what are other technologies and are
there any things we can do to liberate
them and I think the number one thing
you could observe is that the
environmentalist since the 70s have made
nuclear power drastically more expensive
many times more expensive so instead of
the cost going down over time which is
the natural progression as human
ingenuity is applied the cost has gone
up many fold
even though nuclear is provably the
safest form of power ever device yeah
wait let's pausing for a sec so they
made the cost go up because they force
what you would I think argue are
unnecessary regulation yes essentially
with everything in life you have to do
you have to have a certain threshold so
basically their threshold of safety is
what they would call infinite so let's
say nuclear is a hundred times safer
than any form of power I don't know the
exact numbers but that's not implausible
right they'll say basically no it has to
be a million times safer and so you know
at a certain point you can make anything
infinitely expensive by having an
unlimited number of employees an
unlimited amount of containment or an
unlimited amount of time which is
perhaps the most damaging thing so you
have a nuclear reactor used to be able
to build these things in a couple years
now you can basically not build them
your chances of building them are
certainly less than one half and it
takes over 20 years so that's so because
it's so because in effect they've caught
because of the regulations that they've
helped push through through governments
they've caught they've forced the price
to go up because you need more people
you need more research you need more
capital or capital yeah I mean if you
just think about like if somebody says
hey Dave I you know I need some money
like you just came into all this money
through patreon you know you're all
you're really successful now like help
us help us help us finance you have to
plant yeah and it it at minimum it's
going to be ready in 20 years but it may
never be approved what are you gonna do
what are you going to do that I mean
there's no way you want to touch that
and then what happens is because of that
they have to get subsidies and special
loans and then the Green say see look
you're you can't compete on the free
market but it's like you know bashing in
Michael it's like the Tonya Harding a
project it's like Nancy Kerry sieh Nancy
Kerrigan you can't you can't compete on
the free skating market no but you're
not allowed to bash the person
like so my point is that a real
alternative energy policy is just a free
market so that's what you get and you
had much more of that in the 70s than
you do today so I think it's very
revealing that they're not for that but
my own evaluation of the negatives of
fossil fuels particularly with co2 is
that they're much much less than people
think and therefore I think it's a good
thing that we're continuing to expand it
and I think it'd be very good if we
could continue to expand other things
but whatever is competitive on the free
market we shouldn't force people to use
junk because that just increases the
price but I think there's a lot of
different exciting things but but I
think they're generally the opposite of
green energy which you raised before and
so there's a question of why are the
Greens obsessed with what I call the
unreliable with solar and wind
they can't reliably produce electricity
why is that their number-one focus
instead of nuclear and Hydra I think
anyone who's sympathetic to them needs
to ask that and really ask is the issue
co2 or is it something else right so on
the nuclear front would you say the
threshold like so for example what
happened in Japan about was about four
years ago now and they've been saying
that this reactor has been leaking into
the Pacific and you know you hear people
say well now this stuff is eventually
going to make its way over to the west
coast of the United States radiation all
that's up would you say that that well
first off do you agree that that is true
well this is all a threshold issue so
the idea there's this idea that no
amount of radiation is safe but we're
experiencing radiation right now I'm
getting some from the potassium inside
your body right now right off you go to
Colorado you'll get you'll get more
radiation if you I mean I don't know how
off colored people can be but the best
the best go go go go the best nuclear
line ever from Edward Teller which just
Edward Teller is this brilliant
physicist who who helped invent the
h-bomb and he I think never got a Nobel
Prize because he was extremely untie
communist but he had this he was trying
to explain to people that you shouldn't
be afraid of a nuclear power plant I
basically said if you live right next to
a nuclear power plant you get slightly
more radiation than you do by sleeping
next to your wife he said what's the
lesson from this well sleeping with one
woman is safe but sleeping with more
than one is very very dangerous so yeah
but that is that but but that's like
people have no concept that it's all
about the threat
shoulde so the idea is the question
would be is there anything resembling a
dangerous threshold and you don't have
any deaths at all you don't have
radiation sickness what you do have is
scares where people do die because of
forced evacuation so this happened in
Three Mile Island as well nobody died
there is no threat of death from radiate
from radiation but you have these
elderly populations you have them scared
and it's because there's this
demonization and I think there's a big
parallel between the demonization of
manmade co2 and the demonization of
manmade radiation and what I would argue
is that the anti human movement
demonizes everything man-made and we
expect it to be bad even before we
investigate that it's bad to expect any
change of climate to be bad before we
truly investigate it okay so the anti
human movement I like that phrase in
general it just got very dystopian
something there I like it so basically
it seems to me that that these there's
an element to these types of people that
think that everything's about us sort of
that I think you maybe don't think
you'll ever uh that they think that
there's something sort of empowering in
a way if you think that we are
controlling that through our actions
we're controlling the environment in a
way it's a very it's really focused on
you you don't mean that by you know I I
live in West Hollywood where we don't
have plastic bags anymore and a Trader
Joe's if I have to pay ten cents for a
paper bag which I usually do but they
prefer that you bring your own bag I
always think like it's nice that we're
doing this and I try to bring my bag
when I can but like I always think it's
more like we're just sort of doing this
to sort of feel good about ourselves
really because no matter what we do here
especially on that very local level as I
said before China and India are going
through their Industrial Revolution now
they're going to no matter what we do
that makes us feel good here they're
going to keep doing all of that stuff so
in some ways it's sort of just it's like
a combination of sort of lack of science
and keeping things about yourself did I
get anywhere on there it's interesting
because this is often the conservative
criticism which which i think is
generally wrong so I don't think is I
think it's much more that
I think it's much more a hell narrative
I think if you look at the the idea of a
hell and what causes you to go to hell I
think that's much more of a parallel
because if you think of like what causes
you to go to hell
you know you violate a certain
commandment and the commandment isn't
it's not necessarily a scientific thing
it's just that this is what was
commanded and if you go against it but
then there's going to be a negative
consequence it'll get every time there's
an earthquake you know power all these
games I saw fracking Soto's okay now
this is the fracking instead of the
gates here these out is hypothetically
plausible causal relation you imagine a
gay fracking then he'd really I can
actually that would be something I can't
be yeah okay so we're going to this idea
what's the idea that that uh that that
it's somehow a view of it's all it's all
about us but so let's let's look at it
from a different direction if you look
at industrialization is all about us in
the sense of we are taking a planet and
what we're saying about the planet is
this planet is imperfect it's not nearly
safe enough in its natural state and it
doesn't have nearly as much stuff that
we can use right so what we're going to
do is we're going to transform the heck
out of it by using our minds to create
these machines and then create energy
that can feed these machines and make
ourselves hundreds of times more
powerful and the plant is going to look
completely different because of what we
do so I called this human progress and I
think this is fantastic but if you look
at the greens or the anti humans they
don't think this is fantastic they don't
think oh it's all about us isn't this so
great what they're always worried about
is the ecology or the ecosystem or Gaia
you know having some revenge on us but
the focus is not really our power it's
actually our stupidity it's that it's
our hubris they think oh you think you
can just change everything and be okay
you think that you can split the atom
and play God and it's going to be fine
but it's not you're going to get
punished and that's why they always have
this divine retribution except it's not
divine it's the ecology but no matter
what happens every decade they have a
new form in which ecosystem is going to
exact
retribution for our industrial sins it
always changes so there's no there's no
change in in the dynamic there's just a
change in the specific as the dynamic as
each dynamic gets refuted yeah that's
really interesting so basically I think
that they would generally argue that
someone like you is anti science because
they would say oh okay all these climate
scientists say this he's saying the
reverse but what you're saying is
actually they're anti science because
yeah we split the atom and then they go
but some bad shits gonna happen because
of it but you would say well that's what
human progress is and yes and some shits
gonna happen and we'll have to fit and
that's we'll figure that out right I
mean so that that really is the most
scientific yes I'd say I mean
fundamentally to put it in Iran terms I
think they're anti mind so one way of
looking at this as I mentioned that
there's this idea that man-made co2 is
bad man-made radiation is bad but you
know man-made industrialization is bad
so basically everything man-made is
considered bad so you know now at this
moment in time plastic bags are
considered less natural than paper if
you go into Whole Foods right it's all
about natural local whereas little
technology went into this product as
possible right that's what green
ultimately boils down to the ideal think
about what is the ideal Green Earth the
ideal Green anything is what the world
would look like if human beings had
never existed that is their ideal right
the idea what's the ideal form of food
the kind of food that we would exist if
human beings had never existed what's
the ideal amount of co2 in the
atmosphere the amount of co2 that will
exist if human beings ever exist what's
the amount of radiation if human beings
had never existed so that's they have
this very deep premise so what is the
man-made the man-made is simply the form
of change in nature that exists created
by a human mind that's the only
difference right change is inherent in
nature that's why climate change is this
kind of a name term right but everything
changes things
everything is transforming things in
nature but the man-made the only
difference is that it's driven by a mind
so if you're anti man-made you're anti
mind mate and you're anti mind so then
you might ask why do they appeal to
science all the time why do they try to
take the high ground on science and the
answer is because science has a lot of
prestige and if you want to put over bad
ideas in folk science but notice they're
against all the practical products of
science
at least the core one the core leaders
of the movement they're using them all
the time though what do you mean well
they're using all the things that
science has given us right well the way
I think of it as this like would the
green movement if it could go back in
time would the green movement have
approved turning a patch of dirt and
trees into New York City good day a
green piece of a thumbs up to New York
City I guess that best it would have
been a lot slower no chance no chance
rights in Central Park would be
logically their philosophy would have
prevented everything that we know from
existing but they are parasites on that
and then they you know so they're
they're hypocrites but this is the way
that all bad ideas work is basically the
people promoting the bad ideas want
people to contradict them to a certain
amount because if you followed all the
bad ideas everyone would die right what
they want is people to contradict them
so they can feed off of them I mean this
is right out of Atlas Shrugged but then
they can keep them guilty so what they
want for the industrialist like if you
look at the oil companies or any
companies what they want is for the oil
companies they don't want the oil
companies not to work they want the oil
companies to work and be super guilty
and give them money and tell them that
they're great for being what for being
nothing for accomplishing nothing for
producing nothing so it's basically
people with a very deep resentment of
productive human beings who want to feel
important and environmentalism or anti
humanism gave them this perfect vehicle
but if we call it anti humanism they're
going to be a lot less confident and
there will be fewer of them yeah it's
funny because as you're saying that it
makes me think about what I've been
saying lately about just pundits on
television they've never made anything
they've never done anything that's
created anything but they somehow know
how to do everything all the time you
know I mean they always know that elfia
we save 200 million dollars to do this
if with this tax cutting problem and
it's like well you've never done
anything you just keep saying things but
you've never actually created it's a lot
easier to do that than actually create
right I think psychologically I haven't
studied this but this is plausible to me
I've heard different studies that
there's just a deep inferior inferiority
complex among intellectuals who just
don't really feel productive in a
certain way now I don't experience this
myself I mean I think it's useful to
learn how to do certain kinds of
physical thing but I also mean
intellectual who worships the physical
creators so I give them
and I know you know who's buttering my
bread so to speak right I mean I know I
know when I talked to somebody from
industry that they are making possible
my way of life and for instance the
universities are the opposite because
modern universities I mean we have way
too many people going to college I think
but however many people we would like to
go to college is way more than the
number that would go to college if we
were non industrialized and yet the
universities have incredible contempt
for industry and I think it's just a
very disturbing thing that you have all
these Talking Heads all these mindless
students often and they have no
appreciation so let's say even the
fossil fuel companies we're screwing up
way more than I think I mean I don't
even put it though I think they're doing
a great job in general but you should
still have a lot of appreciation for
what they're accomplishing and and you
should still realize that you're paying
them to do that we have this idea where
the non producers can demand this
impossible perfection of the producers
and look down on them even though you're
doing nothing which is like the Teddy
Roosevelt you know the Teddy Roosevelt
quote about the man in the arena like he
Teddy Roosevelt's really into sports and
stuff so he talks about how the man in
the arena is the one who's admirable
even though everyone outside he said
it's not the critic who counts it's very
important right so when you watching a
basketball game but they always know
everything because I was like oh my
friend I only what was going on with
LeBron I mean come on yes I've asked a
human I think that as I do okay so so
all that said when when something like
the Exxon Valdez happens or the BP oil
spill in the Gulf and when these things
happen now I get it
nothing's nothing's a perfect system so
these things are going to happen but for
someone like you when you see the BP oil
spill and you see all of the the birds
and the otters and all this stuff
covered in all this oil and know that
the you know I just remember those days
where they had online you could just
watch that that pipe that burst pipe
just spewing all the stuff into the
ocean how do you feel about that well
it's a negative but there's an it
there's always this issue of magnitude
and I always look particularly if I know
that we have a tendency to be biased
against one industry I'm always
suspicious of these like why is this
foot why is the oil spill considered the
worst thing in the world so to me 11
people died on that
that was the that was the tragedy I've
been 11 there's a thing exploded right
so the guys on the roll are extinguished
right I mean they never get to do
anything again and their families you
know lives are just theirs I mean that's
the thing if you look at what I mean oil
is to use a green term like an organic
substance I mean it's just ancient kind
of life and lots of things in the ocean
like it and then certain kinds of
animals don't like it so and of course
the only point to the bird you know so
if it's on a bird it'll choke the bird
and that's not you know that's not
something that I relish but in terms of
the things that happen to human beings
an oil spill is pretty low on the list
so what I think it shows is this idea
again of the man-made if we accidentally
put oil somewhere it's bad but you know
there are two Exxon Valdez is coming out
of the Gulf of Mexico naturally all the
time in the form of oil seeps so if you
look at the tar sands that's just one
giant oil spill by Nature in Canada so I
think we always have to watch out for
this bias against the man-made bias
against the human I think the sort of
better examples are I mean with solar
and wind there's an example I talked
about in the book where when you're
mining for those elements for the kinds
of metals that you use and in solar
panels and particularly windmills people
die a lot because they happen in places
like China and they're in very dangerous
situations because you're you're dealing
with legitimately threatening amounts of
radioactivity and nobody cares about
that so I always look at what are the
actual threats and non threats of every
form of energy and what I try to do it
and I think chapter 2 of the book is go
through them in a pretty fair way it's
not like I started out being Pro fossil
fuels and it's something that I came to
I mean as a kid I thought some like
solar and then I was never anti-nuclear
really all the Simpsons scare me a
little bit but I just kind of always
figured oh well solar is the greatest
thing but then once I looked at the
equation I thought well it's not nearly
and why are the enviro so focused on
this when they could be focused on
nuclear but I mean so I think the kind
of most you know the things that are
more of a concern like he's a smog and
China right because to me that's that's
something where that's clearly a very
unpleasant and in some cases unhealthy
thing
me that literally affecting someone's
life on that day-to-day basis right so
that's out of there me that's much more
of a concern than an oil spill so then
what in a case like that that you're
you're acknowledging that it's a
legitimate concern right what do you do
I guess you now find industry that
cleans it up right I mean that's I mean
it levels on the cottage I I like to I
like to look back in time and just think
I like to look at the 1800s it's just
sort of a reference point because if you
look at that time they had much worse
smog than China does today I mean what
much worse and so the question is did
they have a green movement that said
this is ruining everything like we hate
it no they had that as a letter that I
mentioned which says basically they
they're worried about running out of
coal because they don't really
understand the geology of it how much of
it there is and they say you know
basically this would be like losing a
limb it would be that bad and again this
is something that has all this smoke and
so from our perspective we think oh this
is so bad it's so dirty but why do they
value it so much why don't they even
focus on that because the value of
energy to empower them to improve their
lives to actually be fed to actually be
warm that takes precedence over
everything else and so then the point is
that whenever you're defining a
threshold of pollution that you need to
legislate regarding you need to have the
context of what's overall beneficial for
human life and what your alternatives
are now fortunately today we don't have
to accept that threshold of smog and
smoke right because we have all sorts of
alternatives and we have technology so I
think in the case of China it's it's a
Midway case where they could because
it's a dictatorship because they don't
respect individual rights in many ways
what they do is they built a lot of coal
plants but it's not primarily coal
plants is actually other things that use
coal they're just burning it in a very
open way but they did this very
haphazardly because they had this
national goal of industrialization
without focusing on the purpose of
industrialization which is human
flourishing so I think if China and
India had much better governments that
focus on individual rights they would
have much less but that doesn't that's
not to say they would have the same
standards that we do because they don't
have the same level of wealth that we do
so it's contextual based on the state of
economic and technological development
and one one great philosopher friend of
mine while
writing the book he gave me this great
analogy about you could say the same
thing about human health so there's a
point that I think is really important
that people are afraid of coal plants
you know what I'm afraid of
you I'm afraid of humans because humans
are way dirtier than our machines which
again shows that we're against man-made
things because we're afraid of machine
waste but not human waste and human
waste and particularly you know the air
we breathe breathe out is biological and
biological is much more dangerous than
non biological so if I get sick it's
going to be from someone in this room
and you know that's how you're going to
get sick and die most likely so why do
we allow ourselves this kind of
pollution right well because at the
moment it's not technologically
preventable in any economic way but it's
much more dangerous than what the gold
plants are doing I haven't seen anything
to contradict that but in the future
what's that he said well what if you had
buildings where you had affordable
technology that could filter all these
diseases then you might say you know
you're required to do this right or
you're required to disclose if your
building doesn't have this so what what
is considered a dangerous thing in the
future could be considered a normal
thing in the present
you